ehrhoff c'est vrai qu'on lisait on est
amis donc moi je connais tous tes titres
mais peut-être que tout le monde ne
connaît pas pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas les amis ambiance bref c'est ça
[Musique]
et les autres c'est sarah fais ils ont
marqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les violences
son plat russe film
plaisir encore naissante a l'air fou qui
combattait je franchis toutes les portes
pour ceux qui m'ont fermez le ban
beverly journée puis j'ai frappé à la
porte
enfin attendez j'ai piqué nos destins
sont un peu celle et je viens ici bas
mais on a fait le show dans l'émission
tu arrives ici s'était invitée cyril est
pas là j'aime les femmes moi tu te dis
que je ne suis pas une
[Rires]
aujourd'hui couteau suisse se cache t
aime beaucoup mais mon ami en poteaux
photo ap photo m à côté de toi tu
connais m6 rotation gamme tout le monde
connaisse autant pour moi mais voilà au
disque à part devrait plaire aux veaux
titre à partir de maintenant est un
album qui sortent de leurs amis c'est
vrai je vous l'offre
avec le nouveau se passer un truc un peu
près là je passe quelque chose à temps
gelé ici marion mais wasquehal au petit
cadeau
à mes côtés je vois la rentrée